You might decide at some point that
you want to drop out of a class for
which you're registered.
There are two times
that you can do this.
One is in registration,
either in phase one or phase two.
During this time, you can add and
drop classes whenever you want.
>From the home screen, click Add or Drop
Classes to get back to your schedule.
Then, under the Action column, click
the menu for the class you want to drop.
Then click Delete.
Then click Submit Changes.
When the screen refreshes, I'll see that
I'm no longer registered for that class.
>> After registration ends,
you can still drop a class
until the withdrawal deadline.
However, if you're withdrawing
after registration closes,
you'll receive a w on your
transcript for that class.
To withdraw from a class,
go to the same Add or
Drop Classes link that
we clicked earlier.
After registration closes,
you'll no longer see this delete option.
Instead, you'll see a Withdraw option.
Click that, and then click Submit
Changes to withdraw from the class.
As long as you drop before
the registration deadline is over,
the drop will not be
noted on your transcript.
That means that until the end of the
first week of class, you can join and
leave whatever class you want.
After the end of
the first week of class,
withdrawing from a class will
get you a w on your transcript.
To check the withdrawal deadline,
visit the registrar's website.
The withdrawal deadline is
typically a little over
half way through the semester.